our main speaker this evening is
lieutenant general roméo Dallaire
general Dallaire joined the Canadian
Army in 1964 after returning from Rwanda
he was promoted to a three-star general
and served in various senior positions
including assistant deputy minister in
the Canadian Ministry of Defence general
Dallaire is the highest-ranking military
figure ever stricken with post-traumatic
stress disorder and continues to advise
Canadian Forces and Veteran Affairs and
matters related to PTSD in January 2002
he received the inaugural Aegis Award
for genocide prevention in London he is
currently a fellow at the Carr Center
for human rights in the Kennedy School
of Government at Harvard University and
general Dallaire joins us this evening
to discuss his book shake hands with the
devil
the failure of humanity in Rwanda the
Toronto Star has called the work a
powerful critic ah for the powerless in
a gut-wrenching description of what
really happened during those awful
months ten years ago so when you please
join me in welcoming lieutenant general
roméo Dallaire
well good evening patient interested
people in the world of conflict conflict
resolution and of humanitarian disasters
and interested people in certainly
moving towards solutions in that realm I
develop a statement over the the years
since Wanda that goes something like
this
all humans are human and there isn't one
human more human than another any
argument flows from the fact that there
is no pecking order in humanity that the
three-year-old child that we found in
the middle of a road one day as we move
between the lines to try to get people
behind their own organizations that
little boy who was dirty and sick and
hungry and his stomach was bloated that
little boy was one of the instruments
that was being used as many other
children in that catastrophe in order to
prevent humanitarian efforts to happen
what the extremists would do is they
would put children in the middle of a
road and the convoys would have to stop
and as the convoy stopped then the
extremists would attack the convoy and
neither killed the people or injured the
ones they were trying to move between
the lines or kill the people or simply
steal all the materials to sustain their
operation and so that one day as I was
moving between the lines with a couple
soldiers that young boy was there and we
expected to be ambushed and as we slowed
down we prepared ourselves and then
stopped and left out of our vehicles and
was no ambush and so we went to the
young child and looked at him in his
terrible state and then there were a
number of huts along the road and so we
started to yell and go to the huts to
see if there
some adults still alive to take care of
this child we were in no-man's land
between the two forces and as we went
through all the huts they were filled
with decaying bodies the massacres that
happened about six or seven weeks before
and we kept going through these huts
with the same result and all of a sudden
realized that the child had disappeared
on us and so we went back and looked for
him and found him in a hut sitting in a
corner and we're two adults male female
and couple children who were nearly
totally decayed and half eaten by the
rats and the dogs and his child still
alive and quite an exceptional set of
circumstances and he seemed to be at
home where he was imagining it so I
picked him up and bought him to the
middle of the road and I looked at him
in his terrible state of sickness and
dirty and abandoned and then all of a
sudden I looked in his eyes and the eyes
of that child were exactly the same eyes
of my three-year-old son they were
absolutely no different they were the
eyes of a human child and they're
exactly the same and it is my belief
after all these years of having to
relive and talk and even write as the
book will describe the horrors and the
difficulties and the traumas and the
frustrations of that genocide it is my
belief that when I decided to continue
to live that I continued to live because
my optimism took hold and in my optimism
I feel that maybe in only two centuries
or maybe one and a half we will stop
conflict because of our differences it
will be eradicated and it will be
eradicated by strong movements
non-government organizations and
hopefully more human based governments
and not simply self interest based
governments as it looks at humanity
and that ultimately that momentum based
on human rights will will gain the Supra
capability to influence governments and
policy and public opinion and we will
one day live in an era where we will not
create conflict because of our
differences whatever they be race
religion economic or otherwise now in
this era that we stumbled into at the
end of the Cold War we found ourselves
in a whole series of internal intrastate
conflicts they were popping up all over
the place from Sri Lanka through Africa
to Yugoslavia and here the promise by
George were senior of in fact a new
world order rapidly fell into a new
world disorder and as we maneuvered in
these humanitarian catastrophes or
security catastrophes I mean who were
essentially two types you had this
Somalia which was a humanitarian
catastrophe where hundreds of thousands
were dying because of lack of water and
food and medical supplies and as we went
in to assist them it turned into a
security problem with the Warlord's and
ultimately clashes that moved the
American people or at least its
government to abandon the Somalis that
it was moving there to assist in
hundreds of thousands Somalis continued
to die as the big powers moved out and
so you had a humanitarian catastrophe
that created a security problem and then
the other sort were the security
problems that that in fact fell into
humanitarian catastrophes in Rwanda is
that you had a war civil war a peace
agreement a peace agreement that called
for an observer or referee as the UN is
the blue berets chapter six classic
peacekeeping both sides want you there
and subversive elements that signed
under duress the peace agreement
started to maneuver behind the political
structures they built up their youth
wing 15 year olds 16 year olds who
became far more aggressive they trained
him they trained him to use the machete
they trained him to hate another
ethnicity and they mobilized them in
this training and equipped them and the
political stagnation that was created by
the extremist politicals stagnated and
stagnated and with no real determined
effort nor new innovative solutions
coming from the big powers who were all
present there with their military
attache Xander ambassadors and her
electronic warfare aircraft and all the
intelligence material that they had this
ineptness of bringing a solution to
break the impasse of the extremists and
hardliners with the moderates moved us
from not only the political impasse to a
security situation that brought about
riots
sassa nations and their I say small
massacres 5 10 15 30 and a particular
targeting of the moderate leadership be
they Hutu or Tutsi
and then in a coup that the broad was
brought about by the assassination of
the president in his plane we saw the
launching of a humanitarian or human
catastrophe which was essentially a
hundred days of genocide
so a security situation that genr
degenerated into a humanitarian
catastrophe and nobody came nobody came
in fact everybody did their best to
abandon they wanted out and the old
colonial powers were convincing all the
other countries that had provided troops
and diplomats and staff were convincing
him that once the African gets excited
because of a catastrophic failure
then they lose all sense of proportion
and they don't act as humans anymore and
they go wild and then the whole mission
was at risk of being slaughtered and the
argument used by the Belgian government
through the Security Council into all
the participating nations was that the
mission would be outright slaughtered
and so you had to abandon leave the
field and essentially let these tribal
situations play out and rapidly falling
right in right into that plan that the
extremists had pondered because there
are no fools and one of the great
tragedies of any of our interventions or
our actions on that continent and
sometimes and others is that we tend to
treat them as dummies their leadership
as easy maneuvered while on the contrary
they study at the same schools we do and
they graduate and their officers go to
the same military institutions we do in
the case of Rwanda the government forces
were trained in France and Belgium and
the rebel forces were trained here and
in Canada and the UK and they know how
to move their country and they know how
to move international opinion and so
they were able to mobilize their country
by fear and by hatred and so that
scenario of absolute horror that was
planned was actually put into action
within hours even though the
international community knew about it
even though we had articulated the risks
however we never would have imagined the
scale it took five days for me to
actually start pondering the term
genocide we had already lived ethnic
cleansing with Yugoslavia that's
sophisticated but it took those days to
figure out
genocide because in Canada as in here
and most of the Western countries I'm
sure I have been educated in the culture
of the Holocaust and to me genocide in
Holocaust were similar and I couldn't
imagine a Holocaust actually happening
let alone witnessing it let alone being
rendered powerless to stop it and so
finally we did acknowledge that it
wasn't just the leadership of the Tutsis
and moderate Hutus but in fact they were
going after the general population and
they were implementing their plan and
for days and days they slaughtered and
killed and for days and days we argued
and we were told by the UN there was no
cavalry over the hill it was as the
media leptin to both feet unthinking for
there was very little media before it
was described as tribalism and well
black Africans killing each other it's
in their tradition I mean we probably
learned it nearly at school or at least
we know about it or we read it in
National Geographic or something and so
we made that slaughter trite Yugoslavia
however was not trite Yugoslavia they're
Europeans these are great nations
they're great religions the Ottoman
Empire we've studied it and debated it
and yet they've killed and chopped heads
off and pulled fetuses out and murdered
and massacred and raped just like the
London extremists did however in
Yugoslavia that was ethnic cleansing and
that was unacceptable and we have to
react to that because of our security
because it's close to home because we
know some of them and maybe because
they're white maybe they know what
they're doing so we've got to stop that
there were more people killed injured
internally displaced in refugee than a
hundred days in Rwanda than the six
years of the ex Yugoslavian war and we
poured billions of dollars of aid and
tens of thousands of troops and we still
have troops and billions of aid going
into ex-yugoslavia
and in Rwanda black Africans killing
each other is insignificant the country
has no strategic value it's got no
strategic resources there's no
self-interest there they're just humans
as one of the country's representatives
told me and there's too many of them
anyways it's overpopulated and so we let
it go and for six weeks emasculated on
the ground because no one no cavalry was
coming I got rid of surplus soldiers
that were simply being targets useless
and eating up the few rations and a few
little bit of water we had they were
inept because their countries didn't
want them to do anything they didn't
want to take the risk because Mogadishu
had happened only a few months before
and if the Americans with only eighteen
casualties would pull out how do you
expect us small countries to sustain
public opinion of taking casualties in a
country that's not worth anything and in
fact doesn't even put our country at
risk in the security and so they pulled
out and my mandate ended up by being
well do what you can and stay there and
negotiate and we'll see and so three
weeks into it my mandate was to see and
to watch and to negotiate that's after I
received the orders to pull out which I
refused because by then we had nearly
30,000 London's under our protection and
when militiamen were all around them
just waiting for us to pull out the
slaughter them another three weeks that
is six weeks into the genocide by the
middle of
made finally the great nations of the
world did acknowledge that this was a
genocide one could maybe forgive them a
bit for not calling it genocide because
they didn't know that's what President
Clinton said anyways he didn't know
about it for as an example in this great
nation and in Canada because we got
cable and satellite and we watch a lot
of the same programs that you do we were
all enraptured by OJ Simpson we were
enraptured by Tonya Harding kneecapping
her colleague the Rwandan genocide on
ABC CBS and NBC got less time than both
of those subjects and is that because
there was this interest in American
population or maybe it's because the
American government on the first day of
the genocide in a Security Council
working room told the rest the Security
Council the United States is not going
to get involved and it is not going to
support anybody who wants to we don't
want to lose more soldiers in a complex
fight in the middle of Africa that has
absolutely no self-interest nor any
security risk to us so finally on the
17th of May yes I get a mandate and they
say right it's a genocide and so yes we
agree with your plan finally for
reinforcements I didn't need a hundred
thousand troops I didn't need
sophisticated aircraft or tanks
I just need needed about 5,000
well-trained soldiers and some skilled
diplomats and some very effective
humanitarians I needed them then within
10 days four by then about 300,000 had
been slaughtered and ultimately nearly
800,000 were slaughtered that meant that
in mid-may there were still another
500,000 to be slaughtered and millions
moving on the roads dying and injured
and so they agreed we'll give him the
5,500 troops he needs
but we won't give them our troops we're
not going to give them white troops
we're not going to give them troops from
the developed countries no we're up to
our ears in Yugoslavia and and that's
significant and so they turn to the
Africans and he said you know this is an
African problem so why not you Africans
sort it out and this is only a couple
years after the end of the Cold War when
we turned to the Africans whom we held
captive in the East West tug of war
during the Cold War we held them captive
because what we did is in the late 50s
and early 60s when these nations fought
for their independence we and the other
side went to them and said who was the
powerhouse here here's a bunch of money
and we want you mr. autocrat mr.
dictator we want you to keep the lid on
this place because we're not interested
in going to World War 3 over Tanzania
and so throughout the Cold War these
dictators were supported and they did
maintain the lid and then all of a
sudden 1989 when the Cold War is over we
simply turned to them and said hey we
don't need you anymore so why don't you
sort yourselves out and that's what
they've been trying to do and so in 94
there were countries that were prepared
to send me troops but they didn't have
the skills the equipment nor the
strategic lift even to get to Rwanda and
nobody wanted to provide them and today
today in Darfur
after goading the African Union to sort
itself out we have it standing there at
the door of Darfur saying we will move a
mission into Darfur and we are accepting
the same inept mandate that I had which
is to observe and report and as I was
saying in May and June in July I'm
observing and reporting
but so what nobody's reacting
it took two months for the first troops
to arrive in Rwanda after the mandate
and they were Ethiopians they were
wearing the brand new uniforms and
berets they had gotten just before
getting on the plane to come to Kigali
let alone had the skills to not only not
intersect or intervene in a war between
the two factions but try to maneuver to
separate the extremists and a militiamen
from the general population to stop the
slaughter and so today we're setting up
the African Union to fail because it
still doesn't have the skills the
equipment strategic lift or logistics to
sustain any force and we are still using
the same term I think it's called
genocide I think it was used by this
country just before the elections smart
move why suffer what Bill Clinton had to
go through weeks of harassment let's go
up front and let's call it a genocide
and the media immediately reacted to
that and said yes it's a genocide but
you see we're so involved in Iraq we
have nobody to go to the genocide so
we've done nothing except discuss in
maneuver in Khartoum now no troops
there's no intervention there is no
lesson learned in stopping the slaughter
and the rape of hundreds of thousands of
people and the destruction of an
ethnicity I applaud the reaction to the
tsunami I mean it's phenomenal I sort of
think a bit saying maybe because nobody
did anything in 94 maybe there's a sense
of in the general population and maybe
even the governments that they feel they
have to do something and I think that's
magnificent but I think we've lost the
bubble how come we react with such
vehemence such energy such abnegation
such generosity to a natural disaster
and when it comes to a disaster created
by human beings we don't want any part
of it unless it is in our self-interest
and Darfur is not in our self-interest
and so we're not going and we're not
going to intervene and we're going to
let it fester and we're going to
continue the same Annette maneuverings
of diplomats and politicians and the
people will continue to suffer and die
in larger numbers than the tsunami it
won't get five cents and it will not get
the political conviction of trying to
solve that problem and so ladies and
gentlemen the 90s and into the new
millennium we've actually come clean in
the world and we've actually articulated
the pecking order of humanity black
Africans who've got problems at home
don't count unless there's something
there for us white Europeans or safe
interventions in natural disasters they
they count and they will get the support
and so my book my book is not a
description of massacres and blood and
guts all over the place it's a credo
Carla cry from the heart saying listen
this is what we actually did and these
are the mistakes and this is exactly
what we didn't do on a day-to-day near
basis from the highest levels above the
Security Council where the fiddling was
going on to rake down the poor corporal
standing on the barrier witnessing a
slaughter and not being able to do
anything and now trying to blow his
brains out because he's suffering from
that injury of these new operations but
the book brings an optimistic
perspective in the end ladies and
gentlemen
we can solve this we can do it by moving
the NGOs into a far more mature plane
and supporting them we can do it by
advancing human rights and standing firm
with them and don't fiddle with them
because we got this new threat called
terrorism and so we'll fiddle with our
human rights we'll fiddle with our civil
liberties we'll fiddle with conventions
because this terrorist they don't have a
play by any of the rules and as we
fiddle with our rights and our liberties
and our conventions nobody's telling us
when we'll stop fiddling with it
nobody's going to tell us when we've won
that war against terrorism and what's
the proof of it and by the by how are we
gonna make our way back to where we were
after
that's not the solution the solution
ladies and gentlemen is going to the
source of the rage in humanity and that
rage is in 80% of humanity that's still
in the dust and the mud and the
suffering in the blood and the solution
is to move there with development to
assist them in coming out of this
inhumane condition and eliminating that
rage that moves young people into the
incredible acts of terrorism and
self-destruction
no wall will protect us on the contrary
we may find ourselves being more
restricted than in fact we would
normally be if we went to the source of
the problem and in those countries it is
in making development a mainstream just
like defense and just like health and
bringing solutions to assist them in
moving to a more tucum of humanity where
every human being is treated and
considered a human and feels to be a
human on the same plane as every other
human
being thank you very much
[Applause]
yes so I'm available for any questions
and doesn't have to do with the book yes
please
general Dallaire my understanding is at
prior to 1994 there was a great deal of
coexistence between the Hutus and the
Tutsis that this was provoked this
crisis was provoked by a clique of
extremists what do you think is their
likelihood of future coexistence between
the Hutus and the Tutsis under the
current situation
yes I'll repeat the question is is that
the the there was coexistence between
the two ethnicities in the past and that
got perturbed and in fact was used by
the colonial powers to maintain control
and power in those countries and then
was used by an elite or a a group of one
ethnicity against the other and so the
question was is there any chance of
reconciliation and I was back there at
the 10th anniversary just last April and
it is a very complex scenario in regards
to reconciliation because you got such a
divergent group or a spectrum of groups
that need to be reconciled may I say
that in my opinion reconciliation and
many of these nations is by empowerment
of women and by education of children
they they will bring about the
reconciliation and the future evolution
of those countries in particular the
mothers who really know what life is far
more than any others and so between the
empowerment of women and the education
objective nonpartisan non imposed
religious education but values and
ethics that they will be able to take
the
decisions and ultimately moved their
Nations and so yeah it'll take time and
there may be a few dust-ups into the
future but I think that ultimately that
will happen and so in a wonda when I
noticed at the end of the war when they
took seized one the rebel forces won
within a month the diaspora the Tutsi
diaspora come back and they had funded a
lot of the rebel operation and they came
back with a lot of money and very cocky
and they started to move the other
tootsies out and toots and Hutus and
they started to gain control and access
and moving economy and moving the
bureaucracy and the judiciary and also
moving power and so I found them to be
very imposing and in fact even when I
went back last April they're all there
in all the different elements with some
smattering of who tooth but they were in
power and the survivors that Tutsi
survivors were still treated some of
them treated as collaborators having
survived a genocide and been abandoned
and then now being treated as
collaborators collaborators creates
inside the Tutsi dimension complexities
let alone the tens of thousands of those
who did kill and murder and they get
such a local judicial system in the
villages of trying to bring
reconciliation and through justice and
so you've got the Hutus who were
innocent and lost everything or didn't
participate and you got the Hutus I did
participate and then you got the
extremists which are an interesting gang
because the whole leadership of the
genocide apart from those who stayed on
the ground who are in jail in Arusha
which I've testified already a couple
times in international tribunal the
intellectual brain
of the extremists are sitting in France
and in Belgium they were the first
evacuated in the first days they're
still there and they've got about 10,000
rebels in eastern Qiu to which the
London's keep every now and again
crossing the border and beating up and
maybe taking a few diamonds in there in
the passage and so it's a regional
complexity and inside the country you've
got these variants and let me just throw
one short example of how difficult it
will be its Tutsi young woman raped 16
15 14 she now is still in the village
and being raped it probably has a child
maybe already with AIDS she lost her
family or destroyed he lost her Hut
she's not taken in by anybody else
because she's been soiled and trying to
make her way and trying to survive and
then you get the rapists the local chap
who was forced yes to kill because they
would have killed his family and so
great judeo-christian values over a
century they're all Catholics and
Anglicans and other Protestants 90% that
didn't last 30 seconds love thy neighbor
did not survive fear and so this guy is
back now and he's in front of the Gotcha
and he give him some some sort of
punishment local support and so on
however his wife and children are still
there they survived they were not
attacked as hot still there his stuff is
still there how does that woman who was
raped
live with that guy in that village and
when will she be supported and what is
the future of her and worse what is the
future of her children it's
exceptionally complex and it will take
time in contrary to my country where we
do not believe in the melting pot we
believe in the differences we believe in
the multi-ethnicity
we believe in cultures maneuvering
together to a common good and a set of
values and ethics
Kagami the president has decided to get
rid of the ethnicities and called them
all London's we got same mostly same
religions they got the same language and
maybe that will work it worked in
Tanzania maybe I'll work in Rwanda but
it is a risk and that's where it is and
that sir is my short answer to your
question okay
somewhere in the back anybody know okay
maybe you're all asleep out there I
didn't see there's a gentleman way in
the back yeah that's you
Civil War there's a possibility that
civil war is going to break out again
especially in eastern Congo which seems
related to what you've gone through do
you have any suggestions for what's
going on there the question is the the
possibility of conflict still exploding
in eastern Congo Congo is now bete noire
of the developed countries in as much as
turned into a problem exacerbated by in
fact a conflict in Rwanda which
destabilized the whole region because we
still have problems in Burundi also and
the Congo has been essentially part of
that abandonment not total there is a UN
mission there
it's totally ineffective we're
interested because there are resources
there and so there are all kinds of
deals that have been worked out the
London's Uganda's and so on we're
interested because there's resources on
that side close at hand and yes maybe
it's a way of building a sort of buffer
zone with them but essentially the Congo
has gone the same route as Wanda and is
the same route that Sierra Leone was
until we finally reacted and is the same
root as Darfur is today my country
decided to send 2,000 troops to
Afghanistan and in fact they deployed in
Kabul and they've even led the NATO
forces there however I argued very
strongly that instead of going to
Afghanistan and yes we participate in
the war on terrorism but that doesn't
mean the rest of the world all of sudden
disappears 3,000 people dying in New
York and Washington is catastrophic I
could hear them as the as the floors
were falling because I had heard people
die and scream and suffer and we
mobilized the world in a few years
earlier 800,000 died and nobody came and
so we reacted we sent troops to
Afghanistan however 2000 Canadian troops
who speak
French and English nor the region our
diplomats know the region we've done a
lot of humanitarian effort there 2000
Canadian troops could have been the
backbone of an effective UN mission that
needs about 30,000 troops and not 8,000
and not troops from third-world
countries who don't have the skills or
the equipment to do anything so millions
have died and millions are still
suffering and yes they will clash and it
will continue the clash as we embed in
Africans because they really don't count
but that will change and millions will
still die and suffer but one day that
will change because people like you are
interested and people like me are not
going to keep our mouth shut
and we're gonna argue for human rights
and there is no one who can counter
argue the fundamental right of humanity
of human beings being treated as humans
and that three year old black Rwandan
boy has the right to live and to be
treated as a human just like my three
year old and no one can argue that
that's not the right thing to do one
more question sir sorry I actually have
two questions got one the first ones
pretty short who do you think was
responsible for shooting down the
president's plane I can give you six
theories knowing all the players it can
be simply the the Hutu extremists who
saw finally the president being more
maneuverable and they had their plan of
genocide of ultimate mass killing in an
ultimately genocide ready
and so the opportunity presented itself
and they went at it
or it could be the other extreme could
be the Tutsi extremists who by shooting
down the plane knew that it would create
a catastrophic reaction knew that the
Hutus had their extremists had their
plan would implement
then ultimately give them the
opportunity to take over the country
again as their forces were superior to
the government forces one of the
arguments I presented in the book I say
you know if general Kagame launched his
forces in the first 24 hours of the war
to fight the government troops but
principally to try to save the Tutsis
who were being attacked and killed and
slaughtered why did it take a hundred
days why did it take 800,000 killed to
achieve that and it's not a tactical
decision because he could have done that
and weeks so a lot of options there and
something certainly to be still pondered
into the future what's your second
question first what is your opinion on
the allegation that the church was
complicit at complicitous in the
genocide yes you had the pleasure of
speaking at Boston College which is a
Jesuit based University right oh sorry
the question is is whether it was the
complicity of the of the Church in the
genocide and I was asked in fact that
same question and present a paper on
that at Boston College and the Catholic
and Anglican churches the
judeo-christian churches were very much
all fair with the ethnic tensions that
were going on and in fact through its
education system never denied it or
fought against it they separated the
Tutsi and Hutu children in the schools
that were run by the nuns and her
brothers and by different
religious structures the london catholic
church leadership was very close to the
government and a it's very interesting
because president Xavier mana was known
as a very practicing Catholic the Pope
was there just two years previous
doesn't say much for those who
necessarily are very practicing does it
and so the churches never stopped the
movement that festered that mu that
ultimately exploded in the genocide and
some churches were the the pastors and
so on participated in the genocide and
made it easier for the extremists to
kill a few did not and died and so at
the end of my presentation i argue that
yes one a century of judeo-christian
education and practice didn't mean beans
when people were fearful of their life
in the life of their children and
ultimately didn't even establish a sense
of guilt in the first while and then
when of course the widows were losing
then scenario changed and to yes the
religious structures the different
religious organizations were participant
to varying degrees to at least the
setting up and the permitting of the
genocide to happen and in some cases
outright complicit and i ended my
presentation by the following will the
great religions of our times be the
instruments of reconciliation of
humanity a world they in fact be the
instruments of our division of our
conflict and be the source of the
destruction of humanity into the future
thank you very much